l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
deuxième lecture du projet de loi
constitutionnelle complétant l'article
premier de la constitution relatifs à la
préservation de l'environnement dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur eric dupond-moretti garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice
c'est le président monsieur le président
de la commission des lois
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
j'ai l'honneur de présenter une nouvelle
fois votre haute assemblée le projet de
révision constitutionnelle complétant
l'article premier de la constitution est
relatif à la préservation de
l'environnement
la génèse de cette réforme historique en
faveur du climat de l'environnement de
la diversité biologique est connu de
tous et je me bornerai donc à rappeler
que le projet qui vous est soumis est
d'abord le fruit du travail et de
l'engagement des 150 françaises et
français de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat qu'ils en soient ici
chaleureusement remerciés
ce projet tient aussi à l'engagement du
président de la république de reprendre
leurs propositions citoyennes de
modification de l'article 1er de la
constitution dans le cadre d'un projet
de loi constitutionnelle nos précédents
débats avaient fait apparaître que les
désaccords se cristalliser sur l'emploi
de deux des 18 mo du projet de loi
ces deux mots qui ont donné lieu à de
savantes exégèse sont les verbes
garantir et lutter vous le savez le
gouvernement et l'assemblée nationale
ont souhaité dans un esprit d'ouverture
et de conciliation faire un pas vers
votre haute assemblée et le verbe lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique a donc
été remplacé par le verbe agir
je comprend au regard du projet proposé
par votre commission et qui fait l'objet
d'un amendement de réécriture de
l'article unique que la main tendue n'a
pas été saisie et je le regrette car
vous fermez ainsi la possibilité pour
les françaises et les français de
s'exprimer sur le sujet de première
importance qui est l'avenir écologique
de notre pays ou soutien de la
proposition de réécriture vous avez
reproché au gouvernement d' entretenir
zones d'ombré et contradictions quant
aux effets juridiques attendue du projet
de révision constitutionnelle je vais
donc m'employer une nouvelle fois à
préciser le sens et la portée de cette
réforme mais quelques mots pour
commencer sur la rédaction que vous
proposez vous souhaitez indiqué que la
france agit pour la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et contre le dérèglement
climatique dans les conditions prévues
par la charte de l'environnement de 2004
on peut se demander à la lueur de cette
rédaction bien timides si finalement ce
qui vous inquiète
ce n'est pas tant les prétendus
incertitude juridique entourant notre
projet que le fait pleinement assumée
par la majorité présidentielle de
renforcer juridiquement la préservation
de l'environnement
al'inverse la rédaction que vous
proposez ne produit aucun effet
juridique nouveau comme votre commission
l'a d'ailleurs reconnu mais à l'heure où
nous vivons une crise climatique majeur
qui inquiète les français et qui
mobilise en particulier notre jeunesse
la première concernée par les
conséquences de cette crise une réforme
purement symbolique n'est pas
envisageable
il n'est pas possible
de convoquer les français à un
référendum pour leur dire nous réformons
la constitution mais notre but est de ne
strictement rien changé
car c'est cela que vous nous proposez ne
rien changer en répétant le préambule de
notre constitution et en renvoyant
simplement à la charte de
l'environnement qui existe déjà
le gouvernement avec l'assemblée
nationale pense au contraire qu'il faut
assumer pleinement la responsabilité
historique qui est aujourd'hui la nôtre
et affirmé que la portée juridique de la
protection de l'environnement doit
évoluer et que ce qui est d'une ambition
doit devenir une garantie je
souhaiterais tellement vous convaincre
du bien fondé du projet repris de la
constitution citoyenne pour le climat
d'abord il s'agit de réhausser la
protection de l'environnement au coeur
de nos principes constitutionnels
certes comme vous le savez la protection
de l'environnement est inscrite dans la
charte de l'environnement résultant de
la loi constitutionnelle du 1er mars
2005 cette charte mentionné dans le
préambule de notre constitution fait
donc pleinement partie du bloc de
constitutionnalité et le conseil
constitutionnel par sa jurisprudence
récente et en particulier par deux
décisions de 2020 a contribué à
renforcer les principes dans la charte
mais il reste d'importantes limites
en effet dans sa décision du 31 janvier
2020 le conseil constitutionnel a jugé
que la préservation de l'environnement
patrimoine commun des êtres humains
constitue seulement un objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle
je rappelle qu'un objectif à valeur
à la différence d'une règle
constitutionnelle ayant un caractère
impératif ne comporte qu'une obligation
de moyens et nécessite pour sa mise en
oeuvre l'intervention du législateur
nous voulons ici mettre en place ce
principe à valeur constitutionnelle qui
pourrait être invoquée même lorsque le
législateur n'est pas intervenue par
ailleurs je vous rappelle qu'en principe
les objectifs à valeur constitutionnelle
ne sont pas à eux seuls un vocable à la
pluie d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité il s'agit donc bien
de renforcer le poids constitutionnel de
la protection de l'environnement
deuxièmement le gouvernement vise avec
ce projet a instauré un véritable
principe d'action des pouvoirs publics
nationaux comme locaux en faveur de
l'environnement et de la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
bien sûr l'article 2 de la charte
prévoit déjà le devoir de toute personne
de prendre part à la préservation et à
l'amélioration de l'environnement
mais ici nous allons plus loin nous
voulons créer à la charge des pouvoirs
publics une garantie de la préservation
de l'environnement
troisièmement et enfin j'en viens à la
signification du fameux verbe garantir
que vous craignez temps je dois avouer
être toujours surpris que l'onf fois du
verbe garantir fasse l'objet d'un tel
rejet de la part de votre haute
assemblée
faut-il à nouveau rappeler que notre
constitution emploie déjà ce mot ainsi
lorsqu'on 46 les constituants inscrire
dans la constitution la garantie de la
santé de la protection matérielle du
repos des loisirs ils n'ont pas imposé
une responsabilité automatique de l'état
pour toute personne malade ou en grande
précarité les dangers que vous dénoncez
sur ce point sont illusoires
en ce qui concerne les effets juridiques
du verbe garantir sur la mise en jeu de
la responsabilité des personnes
publiques
je ne peux que répéter ce qui a déjà été
exposée il est certain qu'à l'heure
actuelle l'état peut déjà voir sa
responsabilité engagée en matière
environnementale mais nous voulons aller
plus loin et créer une quasi obligation
de résultat
comme je les ai toujours dit une
obligation de moyens renforcés
les pouvoirs publics qu'est ce que cela
signifie tout simplement faciliter la
charge de la preuve pour les requérants
et rendre à linverse beaucoup plus
difficile pour la personne publique mise
en cause la possibilité de s'exonérer de
ses obligations
il ne s'agit donc pas de se satisfaire
des carences ou de l'inaction des
pouvoirs publics pour les condamner
ensuite mais bien au contraire de les
obliger à agir pour protéger
concrètement et efficacement
l'environnement la constitution doit
s'adapter aux enjeux et aux défis de
notre temps
elle doit donc être aujourd'hui à la
hauteur du défi écologique majeur auquel
notre pays se trouve confronté
voilà pourquoi le gouvernement et
l'assemblée nationale à l'unisson de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
entendent garantir la protection de
l'environnement
ce combat est aujourd'hui le nôtre il
devrait aussi être le vôtre car c'est le
combat de la france pour le siècle à
venir
merci monsieur le ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur françois noël
buffet rapporteur à la commission des
droits constitutionnels de l'initiation
du suffrage universel du règlement et
d'administration générale pour dix
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre est là messieurs chers
collègues
c'est un bien lourd fardeau que vous
portez monsieur le ministre que de cette
réforme constitutionnelle le poids des
obligations vous oblige mais nous
pouvons le comprendre mais tout de même
il ne suffit pas pour les gouvernements
d'affirmer quelque chose pour que cela
soit la vérité et notre travail
notre travail celui de la haute
assemblée c'est d'essayer de rechercher
cette vérité constitutionnelle que nous
voulons dans les propos tenus à la fois
en première lecture et à nouveau il y à
quelques minutes on est au gouvernement
nous dit qu'il veut rehausser la
protection de l'environnement tout en
disant quelques secondes plus tard que
cela le verbe garantir finalement ne
changera pas grand chose pour finir par
et affirmer que c'est quasiment une
obligation de résultat qui est demandé
de deux choses l'une seul verbe garantir
un vrai sens une vraie portée et auquel
cas il faut s'en expliquer clairement ce
à l inverse on est là pour entériner ce
que d'ailleurs la convention citoyenne a
proposé qu'on peut même estimer de
légitimes dans sa démarche mais dont il
nous revient à nous parlementaires et
constitutionnaliste pour la circonstance
d'en apprécier la réalité des effets et
nous avons toujours dit à cette tribune
que nous souhaitions naturellement que
les parlementaires assume cette
responsabilité de constitutionnalistes
en ne donnant pas ou ne permettant pas
d'ailleurs un conseil constitutionnel de
devenir un véritable gouvernement des
juges d'où la nécessité de la précision
le sénat est donc saisi en deuxième
lecture d'un projet de loi
constitutionnelle complétant l'article
premier de la constitution est relatif à
la préservation de l'environnement
modifié par l'assemblée nationale en
deuxième lecture le 11 mai dernier
notre commission des lois n'a pu que
constaté à regret que les conditions
d'un accord entre les deux assemblées
sont encore très loin d'être réunies je
vous rappelle que le projet initial du
gouvernement d kalck de l'une des cent
quarante neuf propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat
prévoyez d'insérer à l'article 1er de
notre constitution la phrase selon
laquelle la france garantit la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
diversité biologique et lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique n'avait été
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale en
première lecture sans modification
saisie de ce texte
le sénat avait observé que la rédaction
proposée avec une portée juridique
beaucoup trop vague pour pouvoir être
adopté en l'état comme le soulignait
alors la commission et contrairement aux
allégations qui ont été ou tu est retenu
les pouvoirs publics sont d'ores et déjà
soumis à de fortes obligations de valeur
constitutionnelle ayant pour objet la
protection de l'environnement
obligations qui découlent de la sape de
l'environnement de 2004
en revanche compte tenu notamment de
l'emploi du verbe garantir il ya des
faux d'articulation avec la charte il
avait paru impossible à notre commission
de déterminer avec temps un tant soit
peu de précision les effets des
dispositions envisagées
d'une part sur l'engagement de la
responsabilité des personnes publiques
d'autre part cela validité des actes des
pouvoirs publics
le sénat avait donc substituer aux
dispositions proposées une phrase selon
laquelle la france préserve
l'environnement ainsi que la diversité
biologique et agit contre le dérèglement
climatique dans les conditions prévues
par la charte de l'environnement de 2004
c'est rédaction supprimer la référence à
des notions de garanties élevées grâce à
un renvoi express tout problème
d'articulation entre l'article 1er de
notre constitution modifiée et la charte
de l'environnement partie intégrante du
bloc de constitutionnalité
la subdivision d'institutions diverses
agir au verbe lutte et déjà suggéré
faut-il le rappeler par le conseil
d'état viser seulement quant à elle à
éviter un effet rhétorique dénué de
toute portée juridique
je vais bien que nous soyons en guerre
contre beaucoup de choses le goût en
guerre est entre guillemets y compris le
dérèglement climatique
mais dans la loi fondamentale nous
préférons la sobriété du style à l'essai
deux manches en deuxième lecture
l'assemblée nationale sous couvert ou
sous couleur de roche rechercher un
terrain de compromis avec le sénat a
presque intégralement repris son texte
initial en acceptant seulement le
remplacement du verbe lutter par le
verbe agir point tout à fait en réalité
accessoires le texte adopté par les
députés celui ci vous l'avez rappelé la
france garantit la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et agit contre le dérèglement
climatique ne lève en réalité aucune
zone d'ombré du projet initial et ses
effets juridiques reste aussi à
déterminer
les députés n'ont pas cherché à répondre
aux arguments juridiques exposés par le
sénat bien au contraire les débats en
deuxième lecture à l'assemblée nationale
ont fait qu'entretenir un flou sur les
effets que le gouvernement souhaite de
ce projet permettez moi de citer
quelques exemples gouvernement après
avoir répété à qui voulait l'entendre
que son texte visait institué une
véritable principe un véritable principe
d'action des pouvoirs publics en faveur
de la protection de l'environnement
enfin reconnu devant la commission des
lois de l'assemblée nationale que la
charte de l'environnement s'applique aux
autorités publiques depuis 16 ans dont
acte
c'est une avancée que nous relevons
alors qu'il prétendait auparavant que le
projet de révision vise à assigner aux
pouvoirs publics une quasi obligation de
résultat en matière de protection de
l'environnement gouvernement ne parle
plus désormais que d'une obligation de
moyens renforcés
il faudrait savoir finalement ce que
cela veut vraiment dire est qu'elle est
cette notion dont on ne trouve pas
encore véritablement ni la source d'une
véritable signification une obligation
les notion d'obligation de moyens de
moyens renforcés de résultat ou encore
de résultats atténuer n'ont pas tout à
fait la même exception pour donner corps
à cette notion d'obligation de moyens
renforcés
le gouvernement déclare que son objectif
est d'inverser la charge de la preuve
est d'obliger ainsi les pouvoirs publics
si la responsabilité recherchée en
justice à établir eux mêmes la
démonstration qu'ils ont accompli toutes
les diligences raisonnable pour assurer
la préservation de l'environnement
je veux bien mais il faut tout de même
beaucoup d'imagination pour faire
produire ouverte garantir de tels effets
sur le régime de la preuve dans le
procès administratif
la notion de garantie dans le langage
courant comme dans le langage juridique
a une autre signification
pendant ce temps le rapporteur de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale prétend toujours que le texte
aurait pu est à oreille pour effet et je
le cite d'ériger la protection de
l'environnement en principe
constitutionnel c'était faux ou alors
c'est une ignorance de sa part puisque
tout le monde sait très bien que la
charte de 2004 fait partie du bloc
constitutionnel et à valeur
constitutionnelle
il a également déclaré que le texte
adopté par les députés pourrait
constituer le support d'action en
carence contre le législateur ce qui
pour le coup pour le coup constituerait
une nouveauté puisque dans notre état de
droit et conformément à la conception
française de la séparation des pouvoirs
aucune juridiction n'a le pouvoir
d'adresser des injonctions législateur
ni de condamner d'ailleurs l'état à
réparer les dommages causés par
d'éventuelles carences du législateur il
est bien évident que la disposition
proposée ne suffirait pas à elle seule à
opérer un tel bouleversement juridique
si l'on en croit les déclarations faites
en séance publique par le rapporteur de
l'assemblée nationale la prétendue
concessions faites au sénat serait
l'expression de l'esprit de dépassement
et de rassemblement qui comme chacun
sait à nîmes le parti majoritaire à
notre endroit ou moins sainement pas
d'humour
non bien eh bien monsieur le ministre
nous n'avons nous avons nous aussi le
souci du dépassement et du rassemblement
pour tout vous dire nous sommes surtout
assez impatient que ce débat
constitutionnel rentre enfin dans le dur
si je puis me permettre cette expression
est dans un véritable débat de droit et
moins qu'un débat de communication à
celui qui va on se pose la question
aujourd'hui s'il faut gagner la bataille
de la communication de la bataille du
droit ils ont fait le choix de défendre
le droit car c'est notre mission
première est dans ces conditions là la
commission a donc déposé un amendement
dans la rédaction est légèrement
différente de celle adoptée par le sénat
en première lecture nous avons cru
observé d'ailleurs que pendant que nous
avons fait en première lecture c'est
pourquoi nous proposons d'inscrire à
l'article 1er de la constitution non
plus que la france préserve ce qui avait
été notre première rédaction
mais qu'elle agit pour la préservation
de l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et contre le dérèglement
climatique dans les conditions prévues
par la charte de l'environnement de 2004
voilà la proposition qui sera faite à
l'assemblée au sénat
cet après midi qu'il a été devant la
commission des lois qui l'a acceptée
j'entends eux il y a quelques jours
peut-être même ce matin encore de la
part
des membres du gouvernement ce n'est pas
vous monsieur c'est le garde des sceaux
des propos extrêmement désagréable à
l'égard du sénat indiquant que nous
serions ici pour bloquer le système que
finalement notre ringardise serait
absolue que nous ne souhaitons pas la
protection de l'environnement et que le
sénat ait honte et les cas que
l'assemblée nationale a fait un port à
l'encontre du sénat je dirais monsieur
ménisque à vos deux collègues du
gouvernement que même ont commis un faux
pas car effectivement je crois qu'à
vouloir défendre ce qui est quasiment
indéfendable cela constitue plus qu'un
faux pas voire même une foot
merci c'est le président dans la suite
de la discussion générale la parole est
à madame la présidente eliane assassi
pour le groupe crc e pour cinq minutes
un soin monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues pour la
seconde fois donc nous sommes convoqués
pour débattre du projet de loi
constitutionnelle visant à modifier leur
kit premier pour y inscrire la
protection de l'environnement sans
surprise le sénat en première lecture a
réécrit le texte afin d'en affaiblir
selon nous l'apporté raid visant
l'insertion à une sorte de tautologie
renvoyant à la chartre de
l'environnement la charte
sans surprise non plus et après l
annonce par le président que le texte
continuerait de cheminée l'assemblée a
rétabli le fameux garanties concernant
la protection de l'environnement tout en
cédant sur le luth en matière de
dérèglement climatique
nous voilà donc coincé dans un débat
purement sémantique sont la portée
concrète des verbes garantir préserver
et agir dans le cadre d'une navette qui
pourra s'avérer éternelle j'avais dit en
première lecture que nous inscriptions
nous nous inscrivions en faux avec cette
instrumentalisation du parlement une
manoeuvre dilatoire aux effets pervers
puisque loin de consacrer constituent
finalement la protection de
l'environnement ces rédactions fragilise
au contraire la charte s'en crée aucune
obligation de casiers résultats malgré
vos déclarations monsieur le ministre
pour cette raison nous avions proposé de
réduire ces modifications
constitutionnelles non pas au symbole
mais à l'enrichissement de la charte au
principe de solidarité écologique et non
de régression ces dispositions utiles
aurait permis aux juges constitutionnels
de s'assurer un certain nombre de lois
récentes comme la réautorisation des
néonicotinoïdes où la loi à ça malgré
mais les faits sont têtus pardon est
l'objectif du gouvernement comme de la
majorité sénatoriale n'est pas d'être
utile mais bien de faire illusion du jeu
je dois vous le dire
cette farce constitutionnel commençe
sérieusement à nous agresser à m'agacer
d'autant que nous savons tous ici que ce
fameux référendum qui justifie ce texte
ne verra jamais le jour
pour bien me faire comprendre je citerai
le guépard de visconti et son fameux il
faut que tout change pour que rien ne
change
qui décrit exactement la stratégie de ce
gouvernement en matière de transition
écologique avec la complicité je les dis
de la majorité sénatoriale
la discussion de la loi climat en est un
exemple criant nous avons passé deux
semaines à débattre d'une poignée de
mesures insignifiante déjà obsolètes qui
ne remettent nullement en cause ni
l'organisation du système financier de
production ni la préservation des
intérêts économiques et les droits
acquis ce n'est pas de cette manière de
procéder décrédibilise le parlement et
la politique dans son ensemble et je
dois le dire ce n'est pas en poursuivant
avec ce débat stérile que nous
convaincrons nos citoyens nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens d'user de
leur droit de vote et donc d'aller voter
cette réforme constitutionnelle passe
ainsi à côté de l'essentiel sur deux
volets elle ne porte pas les évolutions
constitutionnel dont notre pays a tant
besoin pour sortir de la
présidentialisation du régime pour
engager d'éruption citoyenne et le
respect de la souveraineté populaire
notamment rééquilibrant les pouvoirs en
faveur du parlement sur le second volet
concernant le climat je le répète aucune
réforme constitutionnelle n'aura des
festivités sans mettre en oeuvre des
politiques publiques en vue
il faudrait ainsi et prioritairement
faire respecter la charte
il faudra également remettre en cause
les accords de libre échange et les
politiques libérales de privatisation et
de casse du service public il faudra
encore engagé un vaste plan de
reconquête dans les secteurs clés que
sont les transports et l'énergie en
s'appuyant sur des opérateurs publics
edf et la sncf voit en revenant dans le
capital de certains opérateurs
il faudra enfin respecter les
engagements contractés au travers
l'accord de paris des décisions de
justice administrative récente nous y
oblige
le conseil d'état vient ainsi
d'enjoindre le gouvernement dans le
cadre de la sphère du siècle de prendre
toutes les mesures utiles pour que la
france puisse tenir ses objectifs dans
un jugement du 3 février 2021
le tribunal administratif de paris avait
déjà reconnu une carence partiel de
l'état qui engageait sa responsabilité
pour reprendre l'image de la maison qui
brûle
je dirais que depuis le début de ce
mandat c'est à grands coups d'essence
que vous nourrissez ce feu il ne restera
bientôt que des cendres et la colère de
nos concitoyens
une colère légitime face à l'inaction
climatique de la france mais aussi et
surtout face à l'incapacité du politique
d'agir pour garantir à chacun des
conditions dignes d'existence trop
occupés que vous êtes à démanteler tous
les halls et conquis sociaux nous
confirmons donc notre vote négatif sur
ce projet de loi inutile et inopérant
qui n'a d'autre objet que de détourner
notre attention des vrais objectifs
poursuivis par ce gouvernement je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues dans la suite de
l'exécution la parole est à monsieur
philippe bonnecarrère pour le groupe
union centriste pour 8 minutes
c'est fait monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
n'ont pas souhaité donner de suite aux
trois points soulevés par le sénat le 21
juin et je réagirai immédiatement votre
intervention de ce garde des sceaux en
indiquant qu'il y avait bien trois
points et que le débat n'était pas
uniquement sémantiques je rappelle très
rapidement les trois points le premier
concerne l'incertitude du bep vente
quant aux conséquences d'une garantie
par la nation je veux bien admettre que
sur ce point le choix du verbe est une
incidence mais il y avait deux autres
points qui n'ont pas été abordés qui
sont d'une part notre refus d'une
hiérarchie entre les normes
constitutionnelles et troisièmement
notre attachement aux droits dits
subjectif à une conception que je
qualifierais traditionnel des droits de
l'homme traditionnel mais respectable
monsieur ministre puisque c'est celle de
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen depuis 1789 et donc notre
opposition à un basculement d'une
conception des droits dits subjective
des droits de l'homme vers des droits
dits objectifs les droits de la nature
et à titre personnel
l'éthique à l'égard de l'être humain
reste première et ses problèmes en ce
3ème et demain par l'hymne l'unique
motif évoqué qui me paraissaient
principale avant de vous essayez de vous
développer trois idées je voudrais
d'abord réagir à l'intervention de
monsieur le garde des sceaux assez
incisive qui a commencé par nous dire
que le sénat n'avait pas souhaité saisir
la main tendue où est la main tendue
monsieur le garde des sceaux où est la
main tendue sur l'un des éléments
passent sur les trois éléments mais sur
l'un des trois éléments soulevés par le
sénat où est la volonté de dialogue
où est la volonté d'aboutir à un accord
deuxième élément vous nous dites que les
propositions du sénat n'aurait pas des
séjours et d'une partie nous partageons
pas ce point de vue puisque elle vise à
rajouter à la préservation de la
biodiversité et de l'environnement qui
figurait effectivement des chartes la
référence à la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique qui n'y figurait
pas mais surtout à rentrer dans ce débat
sur le fait de savoir quel est l'effet
des propositions qui sont formulées la
contradiction intellectuelle du
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale sur
ce sujet est encore plus massive puisque
l'on nous dit d'une part que ceux ci
seraient l'expression la proposition du
gouvernement serait l'expression d'une
haute ambition environnementale très
bien mais est qu'il n'y aurait pas de
modification de la hiérarchie des normes
juridiques
or la seule manière de donner un sens au
dispositif que vous nous proposez serait
justement dans le changement de
hiérarchie des normes juridiques
il m'apparaît donc que la contradiction
intellectuelle n'est peut-être pas là où
elle a été recherchée dans votre
intervention vous avez d'ailleurs
compléter votre propos en essayant nous
dire que certes la préservation de
l'environnement était bien dans notre
constitution la préservation de la
biodiversité également mais que tout
ceci était un objectif constitutionnel
et que finalement il n'avait pas de
portée réelle ce n'est pas le cas ce
tout ceci a bien une valeur normative
nous sommes bien d'accord sur le fait
que le conseil constitutionnel un
contrôle moins strictes lorsque il
s'agit
dispositions normatives d'un objectif
constitutionnel par rapport à une norme
législative qui est détaillé précisément
mais nous sommes là uniquement dans la
technique par contre qu'il soit bien
clair pour chacun et chacune d'entre
nous que l'ensemble des éléments qui
sont dans la charte de l'environnement
sont bien le constitutifs d'une norme
juridique qui est applicable dans notre
pays j'en dirai enfin que vouloir dire
qu'une révision de la constitution
serait fait pour une question de charge
de la preuve est un élément assez
étonnant il ya quand même d'assez
nombreux juristes dans cet hémicycle
et je n'oublie pas bien sûr votre
qualité éminente à cet égard la charge
de la preuve c'est une donnée
procédurale
jamais personne n'a envisagé de mettre
la charge de la preuve comme un élément
ayant eu un caractère de près ou de loin
constitutionnel j'en ai donc à essayer
de tracer 3 petite idée complémentaire
ou trois petites perspective
complémentaires pour expliquer la
position de notre groupe en alertant les
uns et les autres sur d'une part quelque
chose que vous connaissez bien la
juridiction et lisa sion de notre
société mais ose aussi surtout la
redécouverte de la portée des
engagements là juridictionnelle isation
de la société est une donnée constante
elle est demandée par nos concitoyens et
elle peut être abordé à mon avis avec
beaucoup de sérénité en utilisant plus
largement le dialogue des juges et avec
les juges et en utilisant y compris nos
moyens législatifs
nous n'avons pas mal je pense à 88 4 88
6 de la constitution vis-à-vis de la
cour de justice européenne ce qui change
aujourd'hui en matière de juridiction et
lisa sion de notre société c'est que les
juridictions s'empare de dispositions
qui ont été adoptées par les états
soient nationalement soit dans le cadre
d'accords internationaux
si vous avez un sujet avec la cls le dh
avec le marais big brother watch
c'est parce qu'il ya des articles 8 et
10 de la cedh h si vous avez un sujet
avec les arrêts du 6 octobre
2020 la quadrature du net à quoi
détourner d'être parent dont la cour
justice de l'union européenne
c'est parce qu'il y à l'énergie parce
qu'il ya lui et rejet et si la cour
de cassation a pu vous poser quelques
débats monsieur le garde des sceaux sur
la notion de décence en matière de
détention
c'est parce qu'il ya eu des dispositions
aussi en cette matière pour en arriver
enfin à quelque chose qui n'est pas
négligeable qui est l'arrêt rendu le 1er
juillet 2021 donc il ya quelques jours
par le conseil d'état
constatant que notre pays ne tient pas
ses engagements dans l'accord de paris
historiquement dans ces pays les
engagements pris par l'exécutif étaient
des engagements qui n'engageait que ceux
qui les écoutaient mais qu'ils
n'engageaient pas les justes ne vois pas
de la même manière
ce qui signifie aussi que le débat sur
la notion de garantie qui n'était pas
pour nous pour vos serviteurs le point
essentiel lors de la séance du 21 juin
prend aujourd'hui un reflet différents à
partir du moment où de plus en plus
régulièrement et finalement d'une
manière assez justicier les juges que ce
soit sur l'aspect européen ou national
et bien sûr le conseil constitutionnel
donne or en effet juridique aux
différents éléments
je terminerai mes propos en indiquant
que le sénat tient la référence à la
charte de l'environnement et nous y
tenons d'autant plus que la curiosité de
la proposition qui nous est fait par le
gouvernement fait qu' à aucun moment il
n'est est expliquée par le gouvernement
en quoi de charte de l'environnement ou
être défaillante
en quoi cet outil mis à disposition deux
pays ne permettrait pas de défendre
correctement l'environnement c'est un et
l'étonnement de ces de la proposition
qui nous est fait vous n'avez lu à aucun
moment un bilan de la charte lication
d'achat d'un environnement qui vous soit
présenté alors que celle-ci à diverses
reprises permis la protection convenable
des moutons dit en matière
d'environnement
c'est dire que j'en terminerai par là
mes chers collègues que la volonté de
dialogue exprimée par le sénat n'a pas
été saisie par l'assemblée nationale et
que le groupe centriste ne manquera pas
d'approuver la proposition faite par des
commissions des lois
merci chers collègues
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à monsieur éric kerrouche pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste
républicains pour notre mintom
[Applaudissements]
si le président mais je préside la
commission des lois monsieur le garde
des sceaux chers collègues
si j'étais ak je dirais que tout ceci
devient croquignolesque alors que le
sujet appelle gravité et sérieux comme
dans un remake parlementaire d'un jour
sans fin j'ai le sentiment que nous
sommes enfermés dans une boucle
temporelle à nouveau nous voilà des
battants d'une révision
constitutionnelle portant sur l'article
1 de notre constitution sans que la
navette parlementaire n'est permis
d'avancer à nouveau cette révision donne
lieu à des débats de pharisien où chacun
gouvernement majorité à l'assemblée
nationale majorité au sénat afin de
chercher un compromis dans un jeu de
poker menteur
ces postures parlementaire et
gouvernementale laisse peser un doute
sérieux sur l'organisation d'un
référendum où la tenue d'un congrès
avant la fin du quinquennat
dès l'origine il y avait d'ailleurs peu
de chances d'aboutir au regard des
délais ce qui révèle l'info ses rites et
manifeste de la volonté initiale de
l'exécutif dans cette entreprise
bref tout ça pour ça alors mes chers
collègues quel est le sens de la
discussion que nous avons aujourd'hui la
loi fondamentale et la préservation de
la planète mérite l otan
d'instrumentalisation politique au point
d'en perdre de vue l'essentiel de ce qui
devrait nous occuper
nul ici ou ailleurs n'a besoin du
décryptage d'un jeu de dupes qui se joue
l'objectif visé est bel et bien qu'il
n'y ait pas d'accord et que la réforme
de la constitution une nouvelle fois
échoué il n'est pas question ici
d'environnement malheureusement dans la
perspective de la prochaine élection
présidentielle
ce texte relève purement du prétexte
emmanuel macron cherche à déporter une
double responsabilité sur le céda et
singulièrement sur la majorité
sénatoriale
premièrement celle danse de son manque
d'ambition face au défi climatique la
loi climat l'a bien illustré sans
volontarisme en la matière ne sautait
pas aux yeux à la lecture de son
programme lors de la présidentielle
sur ce point là on ne pourra pas lui
reprocher de ne pas avoir tenu promesse
deuxièmement la responsabilité de ne pas
honorer l'engagement pris devant la
convention citoyenne permettant ainsi au
président de la république de se
dédouaner la majorité sénatoriale quant
à elle tente d'échapper à ce piège
politique grossier qui est tendue par le
président de la république
elle est face à un dilemme faut-il
offrir un référendum au président à la
veille de la présidentielle de 2000 22
ou faut-il le bloquer quitte à cultiver
le cliché certes erronée d'une chambre
ragarde en décalage avec son temps la
majorité a choisi elle préfère endosser
le blâme de ne pas réviser la
constitution tout en dénonçant
l'assemblée nationale ainsi s'appuyant
sur l'avis du conseil d'état et la
responsabilité du constituant elle
invoque une rédaction juridique
incertaine qui ferait peser des risques
sur notre ordre constitutionnel
elle lui préfère une rédaction dont elle
reconnaît la faible portée normative
sans méconnaître sa portée symbolique
mais en la réduisant de fait à un
placebo
malheureusement ces discussions
sémantique aussi intéressante
qu'interminable se tiennent au détriment
de la finalité
en définitive la majorité sénatoriale
fait ce que l'exécutif attendait d'elle
et vient ripoliné envers l'image d'
emmanuel macron dans une des matinales
radio d'aujourd'hui le porte parole du
gouvernement connu parce par sa hauteur
de vue son sens de la mesure et sa
sincérité nous parle du sénat qui
empêcherait de lancer le référendum et
d'une majorité qui d'un généralement
n'est généralement pas favorables aux
mesures en faveur de l'environnement par
climato scepticisme
fermez le ban là pendant que chaque
joueur d'échecs tente de mesurer le coût
politique de telle ou telle option
qu'elle et les résultats du manège quel
est le coût pour la démocratie et pour
l'avenir de la planète
telles sont les vraies questions que
nous devrions nous poser celle de fond
et non celle de forme
du point de vue démocratique tout
d'abord je crains que nos débats
parlementaires suscite beaucoup plus de
désintérêt qu'autre chose de la part des
français que nous avons la
responsabilité de représenter
et les calculs politiques des uns ne
font qu'alimenter la crise démocratique
aux yeux des autres à cet égard
n'oublions pas le coup de semonce du
dernier scrutin électoral
du point de vue démocratique encore on
peut contester la mise en place de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
considéré que ce ne sont pas 150
citoyens pourtant appliquée qui devrait
indiquer la marche à suivre au parlement
cette posture où cette position qui
confine souvent à la caricature pose une
question légitime mais en réalité ce
n'est pas la bonne question
la question c'est plus celle d'un
président qui ne souhaite pas vraiment
tenir ses promesses en rejetant la faute
sur le parlement alors même que celui-ci
en responsabilité assume son travail de
législateur du point de vue de la
planète
ensuite la transition écologique se
retrouvent l'otage de considérations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec al
parlementaire et juriste avant disserter
à l'envi sur les verts agir et garantir
au détriment de l'enjeu final le
rapporteur spécial des nations unies des
nations-unies pardon a indiqué lui même
que les avancées dans les pays qui les
avait connus n'avait rien eu de
dramatiques
l'environnement est passé complètement à
l'arrière-plan au profit de l'exégèse
pourtant à nous avons nous une
responsabilité en matière de
réchauffement climatique qui peut donner
une réponse négative à cette question
qui peut oser s'affranchir d'une
quelconque responsabilité envers les
générations futures car en effet du club
de rome au giec
les rapports se suivent se rassemblent
s'accumulent s'entassent se répètent
sans jamais se contredire la situation
n'est plus tenable et la crise sanitaire
en est une des illustrations
le pré rapport du giec indique qu'une
augmentation du réchauffement climatique
de plus d'un degré et demi pourrait déjà
entraîné je cite des conséquences graves
pendant des siècles et parfois
irréversibles l'organisation
météorologique mondiale estime à 40 % la
probabilité de ce seuil d'ici 2025
et pour ceux qui préfèrent le droit ils
sont nombreux dans cet hémicycle la
lecture de la récente décision du
conseil d'état peut les éclairer celui
ci a sommé l'état d'agir pour
le climat en donnant au gouvernement
jusqu'au mois d'avril 2022 pour prendre
toutes les mesures utiles afin
d'atteindre ses objectifs de baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sous
peine d'astreintes financières une
future décision qui interviendra donc en
pleine campagne présidentielle
pour les compliments pour les cons plan
tati pour les contemplatifs pardon il y
en a quelques-uns l'actualité parle
d'elle-même vague de sécheresse
inondations à répétition phénomènes de
submersion donne de chaleur au canada
cycle de canicules tempêtes de grêle en
france j'en passe et des meilleurs cette
révision constitutionnelle au final
mérité mieux que des calculs politiques
au regard du défi que nous devons
relever collectivement notre charte de
l'environnement n'est manifestement pas
suffisante
la constitution doit donc s'adapter aux
nécessités de notre temps deux questions
éminemment politique aurait dû animer
notre débat et nos décisions
d'abord quelle est notre volonté
politique face à cet enjeu
environnemental est essentielle pour
l'avenir de l'humanité
nous pensons nous pensons toujours
quelle doit être la plus forte possible
ce qui impose une réécriture de
l'article 1er de notre constitution la
plus ambitieuse possible dans cette
perspective nous étions attachés à
l'intégration de la notion
complémentaire de préservation des biens
communs mondiaux qui nous semblait
centrale et qui a fait l'objet d'une
proposition forte de loi socialiste
portés par notre collègue nicole
bonnefoy le droit de propriété doit
pouvoir être contraint pour préserver
ses biens communs c'était d'ailleurs
l'esprit je vous le rappelle d'un des
projets du texte constitutionnel de la
quatrième république qui n'a pas été
retenue deuxième élément voulons-nous ou
non laisser les français sur ce sujet où
les priver de parole
nous pensons que ce droit leur
appartient ainsi si le vote conforme est
désormais plus que compromis nous ne
souhaitons pas ajouter de l'obstruction
à l'obstruction
nous avons préféré ne pas déposer
d'amendement et nous voterons contre les
amendements déposés par la majorité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur à la marque
pour le groupe les indépendantes en cinq
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le rapporteur
souvent président de la commission des
lois par ailleurs mes chers collègues
la prise de conscience d'urgence face
aux périls que constitue le dérèglement
climatique doit être mondiale ces effets
sont visibles dans tous les recoins de
notre planète le canada enregistré 49
degré 6 celsius la semaine dernière
rendant l'air irrespirable provoquant de
nombreux décès et écrasant tout le
vivant sous ce phénomène de domme de
chaleur des effets météorologiques
violents sont répertoriés à intervalles
très réguliers
la france en a vécu de nombreux cette
année qui ont des impacts sur tous nos
concitoyens dans leur vie mais aussi
dans leur travail
je pense notamment à nos agriculteurs
qui vivent encore les conséquences du
gel du début du printemps sur mon
territoire
nous vivons depuis une vingtaine
d'années une sécheresse est toujours
plus précoces et graves ainsi que des
saisons de moins en moins prévisible
plus personne ne nie aujourd'hui ces
changements et nous cherchons des
solutions afin d'enrayer le phénomène
le projet de loi constitutionnelle que
nous retrouvons dans cet hémicycle en
seconde lecture à encadrer l'étude de
notre projet celui de résilience ce
climat les centaines d'articles qu'il
contient concerne des domaines très
variés ayant pour objectif principal la
réduction de nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre dans un futur très proche
le sénat a travaillé pour insérer ce
texte dans une logique de réalisme et de
pragmatisme
nous ne pouvons pas orienter notre pays
avec la seule logique environnementale
notre transition pour être efficace doit
être ancrée dans le réel
l'artiste unique dont nous faisons une
nouvelle étude est arrivé de l'assemblée
nationale avec des termes encore
différent de ce que nous avions échangé
lors de notre première lecture l'examen
que nous en avons fait la semaine
dernière en commission des lois soulève
presque les mêmes problèmes qu'à
l'origine
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le travail
de la commission ainsi que nos échanges
le verbe garantir a refait son
apparition ce que nous avons encore une
fois dénoncée et lui préférant le terme
aj qui avait été préservé à l'assemblée
nationale la vision du groupe les
indépendants reste la même qu'en
première lecture nous ne pouvons faire
entrer l'incertitude dans notre
constitution
s'il ya urgence il ya surtout urgence de
faire les choses bien
ce n'est pas la rédaction issue de
l'assemblée qui nous sommes le répondre
à cela ni aux besoins ni aux doutes
quant à l'avenir
loin d'opposer nos libertés nous devons
les concilier la protection de
l'environnement passera inévitablement
par les volets sociaux et économiques de
notre système
une écologie humaniste et libéral fera
de nos investissements et de nos
innovations autant de moteurs
primordiaux à notre lutte contre le
changement climatique
demain nous circulerons dans des
transports propres ce qui représente
l'un de nos plus grands défis nous
aurons décarbonés des pans entiers de
nos industries les plus polluantes comme
l'acier ou encore le ciment très
émettrices de co2
notre économie sera beaucoup plus
circulaire nos bâtiments tout au long de
leur vie nous permettront des économies
d'énergie
le numérique qui prend une place
grandissante dans nos habitudes sera
également moins énergivores
notre mois de devis aura évolué et sera
beaucoup plus respectueux mais cela ne
se fera que si l'on s'en donne la
possibilité que si notre relancer notre
croissance sont ouvertes
cela ne se produira que si la protection
de l'environnement est pensé dans son
ensemble et avec tous les acteurs et les
citoyens pas seulement français mais du
monde entier pour cela notre
constitution ne restait une alliée
nous ne sommes pas contre le fait
d'inscrire la préservation de notre
environnement dans son article 1er nous
souhaitons simplement le faire
efficacement en en mesurant toutes les
conséquences il faut écarter le flou
autour de la définition futur du verbe
garantir il faut également se préserver
d'un potentiel glissement vers un risque
de gouvernement des juges je le répète
les arbitrages éminemment politiques ne
peuvent être confiées aux juges doivent
rester le lieu de discussion des élus
les sénateurs qui sont les représentants
des collectivités
cal est pour beaucoup d'entre nous nous
sommes encore nous avons été des élus
locaux savent les contraintes qui pèsent
sur nous sur les maires sur les
conseillers généraux lorsque l'on
construit lorsque l'on fait des routes
etc
ces contraintes nous les acceptons nous
faisons avec
nous sommes même heureux de l'est de les
accepter la france doit donc agir pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
ainsi qu'en faveur de la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et elle doit le faire dans
des conditions que la charte de
l'environnement nous propose cette
charte qui fait de la protection de
l'environnement un objectif de valeur
constitutionnelle est un trésor de notre
bloc de constitutionnalité sur lequel
nous avons la chance de pouvoir nous
appuyer
ne l'oublions pas c'est le sage de la
rédaction que propose notre rapporteur
via un amendement dont nous allons
discuter sous réserve de l'adoption de
cet amendement ce dont je ne doute pas
le groupe les indépendants vote aura à
l'unanimité en faveur de ce texte dans
sa rédaction modifié merci chers
collègues la suite monsieur guy
benarroch pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur cyr
collègues
vous savez il y a des fois où l'on va le
coeur léger participer à des moments
d'antan c'est qu'ils compteront et
d'autres où le coeur lourd
l'eau se rend à l'enterrement de belles
idées c'est un peu l'impression que j'ai
ici aujourd'hui entièrement prévisible
préparer prémédité enterrement d'une
idée d'une proposition d'une promesse
grâce à l'action conjuguée de notre
président de la république emmanuel
macron gouvernement et de la majorité de
droite du sénat
la vie sur terre peut se remettre d'un
changement climatique majeur en évoluant
vers de nouvelles espèces et en créant
de nouveaux écosystèmes l'humanité ne le
peut pas
ces mots ne sont pas les miens ce ne
sont pas les mots je vous rassure d'une
horde de des croissants ou de jeunes
c'est qui ce sont les citoyens et les
citations des mots
du giec qui nous le dit ce membre du
giec qui l'ont mis en valeur il ya moins
de deux semaines
nous n'avons plus le temps de
tergiverser
je me refuse à me résigner à une
inaction de notre pays où comme l'a
encore rappelé le conseil d'état jeudi
dernier à une action trop pop ambitieuse
je le rappelle devant cette assemblée
parfois trop frileuse aux mécanismes de
démocratie participative
mais la convention citoyenne pour le
climat dans ses travaux émis le souhait
d'ériger le principe de protection de
l'environnement et de lutte contre les
changements climatiques au sein de
l'article 1er de notre constitution
soyons clair le texte initial du
gouvernement et celui qui nous revient
de l'assemblée nationale ont des limites
notre groupe le c est le digg le montre
avec les amendements que nous avons
déposés
nous aurions préféré une rédaction
différente plus complète demandé depuis
des années par tous le mouvement
écologiste
mais voilà le terme garantis sort
vraiment irrité la majorité de notre
assemblée
j'avais déjà fait part de mon
incrédulité sur cette position du sénat
dont auprès duquel le simple mot
provoque et froid et et peur mais la
sémantique a ses limites
nous écologistes du groupe geste
comprenant bien que le terme garantie
vous effraie en ce qu'il applique en
quelque sorte une obligation d'action
pour les décideurs publics
vous n'hésitez pas à affirmer que nous
sommes en danger et qu'il faut sauver la
vie sur terre et vous renâclé à l'idée
que ce combat soit essentiel est que
nous puissions utiliser tous les moyens
pour le mener pourtant sur le terrain
nos élus nos concitoyens partout ont
compris et mettre en oeuvre
prioritairement des mesures et des
actions dans ce sens nous souhaitons
donc vivement une inscription dans cet
article 1er de notre constitution à la
symbolique forte de l'ambition
environnementale et de la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
il nous obligerait nous législateurs il
obligerait la france l'impact réel et
les effets sur l'action publique or une
telle inscription au niveau
supranational n'est pas négligeable
alors que nous regrettons tous sur ses
bancs l'absence de procédure de
présentation devant notre haute
assemblée de texte de ratification pour
le ceta par exemple nous pouvons espérer
que cette garantie inscrite au coeur de
l'arctique ne deviendrai un outil majeur
pour définir les contours de traités
commerciaux internationaux acceptable
pour la préservation de l'environnement
de la biodiversité je voulais déjà dit
mais je crains que votre posture ne soit
en rien technique mais bien politique
ce jeu de dupes a certes été initiée par
le président macro et par son
gouvernement
mais vous accepté bien volontiers d'y
jouer vous appuyant l'un sur l'autre
faisant fi de la réalité de l'urgence
vous souhaitez tous à un an des
élections présidentielles pouvoir vous
rejeter la faute de la non tenue du
référendum
il est évident que les celles qui
avancent de manière transparente sur le
sujet depuis longtemps ce sont les
écologistes que nous représentons ici
l'urgence climatique nous vide nous
souhaitons qu'à l'avenir les exécutifs
au pouvoir ne puisse ignorer la
protection de l'environnement dans leurs
actions
l'alternance politique de notre pays ne
saurait se faire au détriment de
l'écologie donc des citoyens de notre
pays
alors osons osé présenter ce projet à
l'ensemble des citoyens
nous ne devons pas avoir peur des
citoyens notre ambition de voter ce
texte dans les mêmes termes que ceux de
l'assemblée nationale est ancrée dans
notre devoir envers les citoyens afin de
leur permettre d'en débattre de se
prononcer et d'être consultés ce projet
de loi constitutionnelle n'est sûrement
pas à la hauteur des enjeux tout comme
la loi climat ne l'a pas été mais il
peut il doit constituer une étape
essentielle vers une prise en compte
plus grande et plus systématiques des
enjeux environnementaux
bien sûr les renoncements successifs de
ce gouvernement sur les objectifs de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre sur
l'utilisation du glyphosate sur le
retour de l'utilisation des
néonicotinoïdes et tant d'autres ne
serait pas absous par ce semblant de
virage écologique nous ne sont pas dupes
sur l'ambition du gouvernement
d'utiliser ce soutien à ce texte comme
faire valoir d'une politique
environnementale lacunaire nous devons
avancer la convention citoyenne les
marcheurs pour le climat les collectifs
des associations écologistes les
scientifiques experts les citoyens qui
agissent quotidiennement nous le demande
même si ce texte va pas au bout de la
démarche que les écologistes portent
depuis des années il est temps d'agir
plus vite et plus fort et nous sommes
prêts à voter ce texte dans la version
de l'assemblée nationale nouveaux
projets retenus contre les enlevant du
rapporteur du sénat
merci merci chers collègues dans la
suite de la discussion la par lettre à
monsieur thani mohamed soilihi pour le
groupe air des pays pour
six minutes m mais le président le sait
le garde des sceaux monsieur le
rapporteur est président la commission
des lois mes chers collègues
ce deuxième rendez vous sur le projet de
loi constitutionnelle visant à inscrire
la préservation de l'environnement à
l'article 1er de notre constitution nous
enjoint à un double constat d'une part
et contrairement à ce qui avait été
augurer çà et là
lors de l'examen en première lecture la
navette a bien suivi son cours
d'autre part la politique des petits pas
que traduisent les modifications portées
par les rapporteurs des deux assemblées
ne suffit pas à poser les bases d'un
compromis
la deuxième lecture telle qu'elle se
profile confirme en état les vives
réticences de la majorité sénatoriale
sur la révision proposée par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
reprise par l'exécutif dans la
perspective d'une adoption par
référendum
nous le regrettons alors que nous
pouvons tous partager la conviction que
la france doit s'armer de nouveaux
instruments juridiques pour répondre de
à l'urgence cris climatique
la divergence de méthodes persistent ces
divergences s'est focalisée dans nos
débats sur la portée des termes retenus
par le projet de révision
mais elle traduit je crois au delà de la
seule sémantique une différence
d'ambition intrinsèque
lors de l'examen en première lecture
déjà nous nous étonnions du fait qu'une
partie de l'hémicycle défendit
l'adoption d'une réécriture du
rapporteur qui a revendiqué
l'absence d'effet juridique la
réécriture alternative qui nous sera
présentée tout à l'heure par le
rapporteur est le président du groupe
l'est républicain semble confirmer cette
volonté de priver des faits juridiques
la révision constitutionnelle le renvoi
tautologique à la charte de
l'environnement
en témoigne notre raisonnement ne peut
être affirmé à l'examen du rapport de
deuxième lecture qui se borne à
déconstruire les conséquences du texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale
sans évoquer les effets recherchés par
la rédaction alternative
opposés certes l'absence de consensus
entre les constitutionnalistes sur la
portée des différents verbe retenue ne
concourent pas à clarifier le débat et
nous elle nous enjoint en tout cas au
parti pris la révision porté par le
gouvernement seraient tantôt inutile
tantôt dangereuse il nous semble
difficile de considérer qu'un texte
puisse être à la fois démunis des faits
est porteur d'une menace et nous
choisissons la voie médiane
la portée de ce texte était déjà précisé
dans les travaux préparatoires de
l'assemblée nationale il ne s'agit pas
d'introduire une prééminence de
l'environnement sur les autres principes
ni de bloquer toute action des pouvoirs
publics
je le rappelle la majorité
présidentielle n'a pas souhaité modifier
le préambule de 1946 dans une rédaction
qui aurait induit une prééminence de
l'environnement sur les autres principes
constitutionnels contraire à notre
tradition juridique aussi le vert vous
garantir qu'ils figurent déjà au sein du
bloc de constitutionnalité est accusé d'
introduire une difficultés
d'articulation avec l'article 6 de la
charte de 2004 et finirait ainsi une
rupture avec la poursuite des objectifs
du développement durable il est utile là
aussi de rappeler qu'au sein de cette
charte figurent également un article 2
qui met à la charge de toute personne
l'obligation de prendre part à la
préservation mais aussi à l'amélioration
de l'environnement exigences fortes qui
ne mentionne pas le progrès économique
et social
or les objectifs de développement
durable que nous soutenons n'ont pas été
mis à mal par cette disposition le chers
collègues nous pensons que le texte qui
nous arrive de l'assemblée nationale ne
remet pas en cause le principe d'une
conciliation entre les différents droits
et libertés fondamentaux
ce point a été rappelé lors des
auditions les verbes en jeu non pas en
eux-mêmes une force qui les fasse
échapper au contexte dans lequel le juge
les interprètes
ce projet qui nous est ainsi soumis nous
sommes en revanche ambitieux
sur un plan symbolique déjà car il
répond à la prise en compte croissante
par nos concitoyens des problématiques
liées à l'environnement
des considérations qui ne peuvent être
réduites à des tracasseries d'un comité
de salut public 3.0 désignation teintée
de mépris qui a pu être entendu dans
l'enceinte de cet hémicycle à propos de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
sur un plan juridique plus encore car il
offre au conseil constitutionnel un
levier supplémentaire dans son
appréciation de la constitutionnalité
des textes qu'ils seront soumis
car il vise à renforcer la place de la
préservation de l'environnement dans la
conciliation du juge car aussi
l'obligation de moyens renforcés mise à
la charge des pouvoirs publics
accompagnent le mouvement
jurisprudentielle sur la responsabilité
offert 20 encore récemment
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
rapporteur réformer la constitution
n'est jamais un acte anodin
maintenant votre désaccord avec la
réforme ambitieuse engagé par la
majorité présidentielle
dans la continuité des travaux de la
convention citoyenne vous nous présenter
aujourd'hui une proposition de
réécriture qui se cristallisent encore
sur les verbes employés une proposition
qui enserre à nouveau la révision
proposée dans les conditions de la
charte de 2004 il ressort des travaux
préparatoires du sénat que cette
rédaction ne produira pas d'effets
juridique si nous poussons le
raisonnement à son terme devant nous
donc comprendre que soutenir le oui au
référendum consisterait à convaincre les
citoyens de se rendre aux urnes pour
approuver une révision constitutionnelle
dont les auteurs revendiquent qu'elle
n'aura pas de porter ce parti free
cynique nous paraît très en deçà de
l'urgence environnementale en présence
et le groupe r des pays ne pourra se
résoudre à voter le projet de révision
constitutionnelle ainsi réécrit et
minorée par la majorité de notre haute
assemblée merci chers collègues
la suite de la discussion la part de
monsieur jean pierre corbisez pour le
groupe rdse pour cinq minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je veux dire des cimetières
collègues
l'arrêt du conseil d'état daté du 1er
juillet dernier intitulé commune de
grande synthe dans le nord tombe à pic
l'instabilité juridique a déjà débuté et
la conséquence de l'insuffisance des
efforts de l'état en matière
environnementale certes depuis de
nombreuses années dans le monde comme
dans notre pays le contentieux
climatique en est qu à ses balbutiements
le verdissement récent de la
jurisprudence administrative et
constitutionnelles poursuivra son cours
avec ou sans le projet de loi
constitutionnelle l'avis du conseil
d'état rappelle que le principe de la
protection de l'environnement occupe
déjà la plus haute place dans la
hiérarchie des normes l'inscription
l'article 1er le coureur conférerait
donc aucune prééminence d'ordre
juridique sur les autres normes
constitutionnelles ce que laissait n'a
fait mine de craindre
pourtant les auditions menées nous ont
assez bien éclairé il n'y aura pas de
dérèglement du contentieux
malgré la volonté du gouvernement de
porter un effet accélérateur de
l'engagement de la responsabilité pour
faute des pouvoirs publics
le professeur dominique rousseau a
rappelé qu'il ne fallait pas accorder
une valeur juridique plus contraignantes
au terme garantir ou préservés étant
donné qu'aucun droit et absolue et que
le droit constitutionnel ne fait pas la
distinction entre une obligation de
moyens et une obligation de résultat si
la réforme devait aboutir les
inquiétudes devraient rapidement se
dissiper
du fait du double filtrage en matière de
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité à savoir la saisine
indirecte du conseil par les parties et
le contrôle préalable opéré par le
conseil d'état et la cour de cassation
est rappelons le le conseil
constitutionnel avant de se prononcer
anticipe les incidences économiques
sociales et politiques de ces décisions
et on tient compte
la commission des lois du sénat choisit
donc de maîtriser les conséquences de la
réforme pour qu'elle n'ait très
exactement aucun effet y compris
symbolique plus que plus que juridique
cette réforme est symbolique et la
constitution recèle bien des symboles
qui ne nous viendrait pas à l'esprit de
contester aujourd'hui et au delà des
symboles
si le gouvernement veut nous prouver
qu'il entend placer la préservation de
l'environnement
parmi les priorités de l'action de la
france ils pouvaient nous le démontrer
par des actes à commencer par un
renforcement de l'ambition de la loi que
l'humain pour l'instant tel n'est pas le
cas
certes le gouvernement est allé sans
doute aller un peu vite en besogne
la charte de l'environnement quant à
elle avait impliqué la constitution d'un
comité d'experts présidé par monsieur
coppens et fut l'objet d' assises
territoriales la politique
environnementale regard du manque
d'adhésion d'un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens inquiets à juste titre tous
ses conséquences sociales mais était
qu'on leur s'y attellent plus longuement
nous sommes donc pris dans l'étau de jeu
politicien se concrétisera par cette
navette infinie le citoyen n'est pas
dupe et l'issue de ces débats ne
satisfera personne
ceux qui voudraient aller plus loin dans
la préservation de l'environnement
estimant que cette mesure est purement
cosmétique ceux qui sont d'un avis
contraire
la jugeront dangereuse je constate
d'ailleurs qu'entre la première à la
deuxième lecture le projet de loi a
perdu un certain nombre de voix à
l'assemblée nationale et pendant que
nous attardons sur un débat sémantique
complètement superfétatoire lui le
climat s'emballe tergiverser et
temporise et nos actions c'est
l'assurance que les restrictions à nos
libertés seront à l'avenir plus sévère
est abrupte quant à l'anticipation
elle ne garantit que la transition
écologique sera progressive et juste
or le haut conseil pour le climat
persiste dans son analyse en raison du
retard accumulé par la france le rythme
actuel de réductions annuelles devraient
pratiquement doubler sur la période du
troisième budget
carbone c'est à dire entre 2024 et 2028
nous n'y sommes pas le giec dans son
pré-rapport produire 1,2 affirme sans
hésiter que l'homme ne survivrait pas à
un changement climatique majeur
contrairement à la planète sans
changement radical de comportement
quelle que soit la fin de cette aventure
parlementaire il est plus que certain
que la france n'agit pas comme elle le
devrait
pour la préservation de l'environnement
et contre le dérèglement climatique
alors on peut graver dans le marbre que
la france agit et cela serait conforme à
la réalité puisqu'elle l'a si malgré
tout cette réforme n'apporterait
strictement rien si la version proposée
par le sénat devait être retenu en
l'absence de consensus des deux chambres
lassé par ces manoeuvres comme nous le
sommes nous même le citoyen se déplacera
t-il si le référendum devait avoir lieu
rien n'est moins sûr comment premier à
tulle en première lecture je m'opposerai
avec une partie de mon groupe au texte
du sénat
je vous dis merci chers collègues dans
la suite et la fin de cette discussion
générale la parole et astrid bas pour le
groupe l'est républicain pour 14 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci nous sommes tous au bout
je me suis le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président
rapporteur chers collègues grâce à la
charte de l'environnement voulu par le
président jacques chirac
la protection de l'environnement est une
exigence constitutionnelle depuis 2005
alors pourquoi cette nouvelle réforme
constitutionnelle
que va-t-elle changer quelles nouvelles
obligations implique-t-elle personnes
monsieur le garde des sceaux n'a été
capable de le dire ni la convention
citoyenne
ni le gouvernement ni même le conseil
d'état qui a cependant exprimé avec
netteté ses réserves
c'est que les implications de ce texte
sont en réalité inconnu et même
imprévisible et seule chose qui soit
certaine c'est que l'article 1er de la
constitution n'a par lui même pas plus
de valeur juridique que la charte de
l'environnement
la distinction entre règles
constitutionnelles et objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle ne dépend pas de la
localisation de la norme
constitutionnelle dans les textes
fondamentaux
le nouvel article 1er et la charte
serait contradictoire c'est la deuxième
certitude la charte dit en effet dans
son article 6 que je la cite les
politiques publiques doivent promouvoir
un développement durable et à cet effet
elle concilie la protection et la mise
en valeur de l'environnement le
développement économique et le progrès
social
l'article 1er dirais pour sa part si ce
texte était adopté que la république
garantit la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique
chaque mot compte endroit préservation
est plus fort que protection et mise en
valeur
mais ce n'est pas l'essentiel garantir
exclu concilier la garantie de la
protection et de la mise en valeur de
l'environnement ne serait donc pas
corrélées comme dans la charte à
l'exigence de conciliation avec le
développement économique et le progrès
social
c'est le choix politique c'est la raison
pour laquelle en effet monsieur le
ministre votre projet ne peut pas être
sans conséquence troisième élément de
certitude la combinaison de l'article 6
de la charte et de nouvel article
premier sera par conséquent impossible
ce sera un vin ou l'autre et puisque la
nouvelle règle fixée à l'article 1er
sera la plus récente
c'est normalement elle qui s'imposera
pour trancher le conflit de normes en
donnant un effet utile nécessairement à
la modification de l'article 1er dont
nous délibérons dans le cas contraire le
texte qui nous est proposée serait
d'ailleurs pratiquement dépourvu de tout
porter un coup d'épée dans l'eau qui ne
mériteraient ni un vote du parlement ni
encore moins le recours au référendum le
peuple français ne saurait être convoqué
pour ne rien décider
un référendum ne peut se réduire à une
simple opération de communication cela
j'ai compris monsieur le garde des
sceaux que vous n'en vouliez pas le
rideau de fumée répandu autour de ce
projet ne semble pas pour autant vous
déranger loin de le dissiper et de nous
éclairer sur la portée réelle de ce
texte vous vous en remettez en effet en
quelque sorte à la sagesse du conseil
constitutionnel pour déterminer a
posteriori le contenu du changement
proposé cela s'appelle un saut dans
l'inconnu
vous paraissez vous accommoder de 7,1
gong incongruité 1 a pourtant aucun
précédent dans notre histoire
constitutionnelle
elle laisserait le législateur de demain
dans l'incertitude et elle placerait les
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui sous la menace
de nouvelles questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité au résultat tout
aussi incertain après la deuxième
lecture de l'assemblée nationale qui n'a
en réalité tenu aucun compte de nos
travaux le choix entre lutter et agir
étant en réalité accessoires s'agissant
du réchauffement climatique
nous devrions adopter ce texte comme
s'ils étaient à prendre ou à laisser
en somme l aveugle et renoncé à exercer
pleinement notre responsabilité de
constituants accepter aussi ce cas
singulier d'un compétences
constitutionnelles comme il ya des cas
d'incompétence législatives et que nul
juridiction ne pourrait évidemment
censuré mais si nous n'avons pas le
droit d'adopter une loi flou à plus
forte raison
devrions-nous nous interdire de voter
une règle constitutionnelle
ectoplasmique un objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle clair celui de la
charte vaudra toujours mieux qu'une
règle constitutionnelle indéterminée et
ambigu
cette révision constitutionnelle était
la constitution ce que les montres de
dali sont à l'horlogerie
ce pourrait être une nouvelle
démonstration de votre sens artistique
monsieur le garde des sceaux
mais en l'occurrence votre amour-propre
d'auteur ne risque pas d'être frustré
puisque le texte que vous défendez n'est
pas le vôtre c'est le fruit des
réflexions d'un aréopage qui ne sait pas
même donner le mal de vous demander
votre avis et cet aréopage n'a
probablement pas pris le temps non plus
de mettre son expertise juridique au
niveau de l' expertise écologique dont
il se prévaut à cet égard il n'a qu'une
lointaine parenté avec l'antiquité
grecque à athènes
les 150 archontes du mont arès
qu'ils n'avaient pas quant à eux été
choisi au hasard étaient tous issus des
plus haute magistrature
cette différence s'explique sans doute
un résultat aussi désolant pour la
constitution que pour l'écologie nul
institutions de la république or le
sénat n'a pourtant osé remanié ce projet
de loi constitutionnelle pour lui faire
prendre sens et lui apporter la sécurité
juridique qui est nécessaire il faut
remercier le président buffet de s'y
être attelé avec l'efficacité et la
sagacité que nous lui connaissons
peut-on imaginer une révision
constitutionnelle celle en l'accord du
président de la république du
gouvernement de l'assemblée nationale du
sénat et finalement du peuple français
appelés à décider par référendum sur un
texte dont le contenu réel reposerait
sur une contradiction sans doute
délibérée entre deux norme
constitutionnelle opposés
dites nous ce que vous voulez vraiment
monsieur le garde des sceaux vont rester
au milieu du gué
si vous voulez rejeté dans les
oubliettes de l'histoire la notion de
développement durable parce qu'elle est
à vos yeux dépasser assumer le
franchement et ne tergiversez plus
tranché la question et ne laissez pas
subsister un article 6 de la charte de
l'environnement orthogonale au texte que
vous voulez faire adopter dit clairement
ce que vous n'avez écrit obscurément à
savoir que la garantie de la
préservation de l'environnement est plus
important à vos yeux que le
développement économique et le progrès
social et que vous voulez donc faire
prévaloir celle ci sur celle là vous
avez le droit d'avoir cette conviction
nous ne la partageons pas mais pour la
clarté du débat il est essentiel de dire
aux français qu'il ya d'un côté ceux
qu'ils veulent inscrire la politique
écologique dans le cadre du
développement durable nous en sommes est
ce vous en êtes qui veulent en faire
sortir
vous avez raison rappelé que le conseil
constitutionnel a l'habitude de
concilier des principes constitutionnels
dont les implications foncé
ces petits bouts d'être opposé c'est
même le coeur de sa fonction dans
l'application de nos principes
fondamentaux
mais parmi nos droits fondamentaux il
n'existe pas de droits contradictoires
mais seulement des droits de nature
différente chacun avec leurs limites
fixées par la loi
ils ne sont pas antagonistes mais
relatif
ce qui n'est tout de même pas la même
chose et permet de trouver des compromis
le plus bel exemple c'est la liberté
dans l'article 4 de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme dit qu'elle consiste à
pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne nuit pas à
autrui
cela implique de concilier les droits
des uns avec la liberté des autres
aucun droit n'étant absolue l'article 4
en font c'est d'ailleurs le clou
l'exercice des droits naturels de chaque
homme n'a de bornes que celles qui
assurent aux autres membres de la
société les mêmes droits partout la même
logique est ainsi à l'oeuvre des droits
sont reconnus
puis leurs limites sont énoncés avec
partout le souci de concilier droits
individuels et intérêt général
et c'est la même chose avec l'article 6
de la charte de l'environnement qui
appelle une conciliation entre
l'écologique l'économique et le social
alors oui dans ces cas le conseil
constitue le constitutionnel sait ce
qu'il a à faire directement d'idées par
l'énoncé même de nos principes
fondamentaux
il ne s'érige pas en constituant délégué
mais si on lui demande d'un côté de
concilier l'écologique l'économique et
le social
puis de l'autre de garantir seulement
l'écologique sans aucune mention de
l'économique et du social
il est confronté à une authentique
contradictions et il sera bien obligé de
la résoudre pour donner une portée utile
vous le souhaitez et il devra le faire
aux nouveaux textes en rejetant le
développement durable dans un passé
lointain
le conseil constitutionnel ne peut en
effet refusé de donner son plein effet
utile à un texte adopté par le pouvoir
constituant le choix sera binaire il n'y
a pas de moyen terme entre le droit à la
protection de l'environnement posés par
la charte qui trouve sa limite dans les
exigences du développement économique et
du progrès social et la garantie
la protection de l'environnement proposé
par la convention citoyenne qui serait
absolue puisque aucune limite n'était
non c'est pour antant père et d'apporter
telle est d'ailleurs sa seule raison
d'être
malgré tous les efforts faits pour le
dissimuler
en adoptant cette révision
constitutionnelle dans les termes votée
par l'assemblée nationale le parlement
et le peuple français ce lierait les
mains
il signerait un chèque en blanc au
conseil constitutionnel et aux groupes
de pression susceptible de le saisir
il contraindrait gravement les
gouvernements et les législateurs de
demain dans l'exercice même de la
souveraineté nationale
aucune loi ne pourrait plus
constitutionnellement venir atténuer ou
coryse et la rigueur et la portée de
mesures législatives déjà prises pour
renforcer la protection de
l'environnement
le président de la république qui a
engagé ce processus de révision
constitutionnelle devrait pourtant se
souvenir que lorsqu'il lui a fallu
renoncer dans la précipitation à
l'écotaxe d'ailleurs voté contre la
position du sénat ils n'étaient
finalement peut-être pas si inutile que
le législateur et eu alors la faculté
constitutionnelle d' atténuer les
contraintes excessives imposées au nom
de l'écologie pour mettre fin au
mouvement des gilet jaune
c'est ce qui a permis de désamorcer la
crise en ajoutait la préoccupation
économique et social à la préoccupation
environnementale qui seules avaient été
prises en compte à l'origine et c'est
ainsi que la charte prévoit que le
législateur puisse procéder
or cette faculté nous ne l'aurions plus
demain si les pouvoirs du parlement
devait être drastiquement limités par un
texte comme celui qui nous est présenté
et c'est donc aussi en protecteur de nos
institutions de la fonction
présidentielle et de la mission du
parlement que le sénat doit rejeter la
rédaction proposée par la convention
citoyenne et souscrire à la proposition
de notre commission des lois de réécrire
le texte
nous ne devons pas aliéner notre
capacité souveraine de légiférer le
parlement ne doit pas se soumettre par
avance aux aléas d'une jurisprudence
constitutionnelle qui n'auraient pas été
encadrées par l'expression claire de la
volonté du constituant ce renoncement
serait pour lui une véritable abdication
c'est au gouvernement ainsi qu'au
parlement quand la loi est nécessaire de
déterminer librement la politique
écologique de la nation il leur
appartient aussi d'en changer
si l'intérêt national et la volonté du
peuple le commande sans que pèsent sur
eux
l'épée de damoclès d'un interdit
invisible la constitution ne saurait
prendre des gages sur les politiques de
demain
qu'il s'agisse de l'environnement ou d
autres domaines de l'action publique la
république doit pouvoir continuer à
préférer la voie étroite mais féconde du
développement durable à l'écologie de la
décroissance que ce projet vise à
inscrire dans le marbre de notre loi
fondamentale
merci cercles oeil le cher collègue la
discussion générale et klose monsieur le
président la commission des lois vous
souhaitez une suspension de séance pour
examiner les amendements
combien de temps 20 minutes devrait
suffire largement 20 minutes
donc on se donne rendez-vous à 17h45 les
745 très bien merci je suis très bien à
toute la séance est suspendue
la séance est reprise la discussion
générale étant close nous passons à
discussion des articles et sur l'article
unique nous avons
premier amendement numéro 6 monsieur
folio oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues je vais pas revenir sur les
éléments qui ont été excellents
développé par notre président de la
commission des lois rapporteur de ce
texte et par mon collègue et ami
philippe bonnecarrère
mais à l'instar de ce que j'avais dit
lors de la première séance la première
lecture je voudrais monsieur le ministre
vous dire simplement que en ce qui me
concerne je ne voudrais pas ce texte
parce que commun comme je l'avais dit
comme je l'avais affirmé je pense que il
est dangereux de modifier la
constitution en fonction et au gré des
éléments de d'opportunités que ce soit
des opportunités politiques ou autres
parce que toucher à la loi fondamentale
ce n'est pas quelque chose d'anodin et
donc dans ce dans ce cadre là je pense
qu' il est il est important de veiller à
une certaine stabilité de la loi
fondamentale
d'une part vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que finalement l'adoption de ce
texte est de cette modification de la
constitution
je vous cite n'aurait aucun effet
juridique nouveau alors à quoi bon
à quoi bon modifier la constitution si
cela ne doit permettre de n'avoir aucun
effet juridique nouveau ensuite je vais
pas revenir sur sur des éléments et
cette notion de garantie telle qu'elle a
été développée par nos collègues et
toute cette difficulté que cela va
entraîner en termes de normes juridiques
j'ai rencontré plus de 200 maires de mon
département
ces dernières semaines il y en a pas un
qui me dit il est important de modifier
la constitution
je vois un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens y en a pas un qui me dit
c'est important de modifier la
constitution
certes la lutte contre le changement
climatique est quelque chose d'essentiel
et de fondamental mais par rapport à
cela il faut des actes
dans le cadre des politiques menées en
matière de défense de l'environnement
mais ce n'est pas en touchant la norme
juridique que
nous allons résoudre les problèmes et
donc à ce stade-là et dans ce cadre là
je pense qu'il est important que le
parlement et le sénat plus
particulièrement dans sa grande sagesse
donne un signal qui est dire finalement
on ne rentre pas dans ce jeu là est la
meilleure façon de ne pas rentrer ce jeu
là c'est ce sont toutes de voter cet
amendement qui est un amendement de
suppression de cet article pour ne pas
modifier la constitution est resté sur
l'équilibré du texte tel que nous
l'avons aujourd'hui
merci cher collègue monsieur rapporteur
président porteur c'est une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable
je rappelle que cet amendement a déjà
été déposée en première lecture que nous
n'avons pas retenu pour la raison simple
c'est qu'effectivement il veut supprimer
l'article 1er est la commission des lois
a décidé non pas de supprimer l'article
1er mai de le modifier en conséquence de
quoi ça notre collègue le retire ce sera
un avis défavorable
merci à monsieur ministre merci monsieur
le président mais ma vie bien sûr pour
le gouvernement ce que vous voulez en
réalité monsieur le sénateur c'est
supprimer l'objet même de cette réforme
prendrait que c'est une réforme que je
porte que porte le gouvernement
on ne peut qu'être défavorable votre
amendement je déplore que vous n'ayez
pas rencontré un citoyen vous disant que
cette réforme était indispensable nous
en avons contrés quant à 950 mhz et sans
doute n'est-ce pas suffisant
merci il est maintenu cet amendement il
est maintenu donc je mets aux voix avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour et
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté deux
amendements identiques celui de la
commission des lois l'amendement numéro
3 tout d'abord cet amendement il vise à
modifier l'article 1er qui arrive de
l'assemblée nationale dans la rédaction
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure à
l'occasion de la discussion générale
je vous ordonne lecture la france bien
sûr agit pour la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et contre le dérèglement
climatique dans les conditions prévues
par la charte de l'environnement de 2004
inutile de prolonger des explications
que nous avons déjà donné sur le verbe
garantir et surtout sur notre volonté de
renvoyer je suis dire cet article
premier à la charte de 2004 faisant
partie elle-même du bloc constitutionnel
les préservant les équilibres entre sur
les valeurs du développement durable
merci l'amendement 5 de monsieur
retailleau monsieur bah monsieur le
président comme chacun aura pu le
constater c'est le même amendement que
celui de la commission des lois
et c'est pour nous l'occasion de
souligner qu'il ne peut pas y avoir la
moindre feuille de papier à cigarette
entre nous groupe l air et la commission
des lois
il peut y avoir plusieurs politiques
écologiques le gouvernement avance
masqué avec la sienne car c'est une
politique écologique qui vise grâce à
une révision constitutionnelle à rompre
avec le développement durable qui
concilie écologie économie et progrès
social
nous mentionnons la charte de
l'environnement parce que nous sommes
pour le développement durable et nous
demandons par conséquent à ce que
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
saisisse notre main tendue pour parvenir
à un accord sur cette base nous pensons
que les français sont profondément
attaché au développement durable qu'ils
ne veulent ni d'une écologie punitive ni
d'une écologie de la décroissance
ils veulent
écologie le développement économique
celui de l'emploi et le progrès social
c'est le sens de cet amendement comme de
celui de la commission des lois
merci chers collègues en discussion
comme une âme en demande numéro neuf
semaines à auch mission commune nous
souhaitons par cet amendement intégré
dans l'objectif de préservation de
l'environnement diversité biologique de
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
la notion d'amélioration constante ce
principe permettrait de consacrer une
obligation à il est allumé excusez moi
je redémarre donc voila tout d'abord au
préalable bien bien entendu nous avons
déposé un certain nombre d'amendements
en tenant compte du fait que les
amendements présentés par la commission
des lois et le groupe l'est républicain
entre lesquels il n'existe pas
l'épaisseur d'une feuille de papier à
cigarette mais nous l'avions bien
compris et qui tous les deux bien
entendu met en avant des certain nombre
d'arguments concernant l'écologie de la
décroissance face à l' écologie
pragmatique sur pas arriver à comprendre
exactement de quoi nous parlions mais
enfin on aura le temps dans un autre
débat de d'évoquer ces sujets on a
essayé de le faire mais manifestement il
n'y a pas de réponse
donc en ce qui nous concerne nous avons
déposé un certain nombre d'amendements
tenant compte du fait que les
amendements des républicains de la
commission des lois sur et
vraisemblablement adopté et que donc
nous nous retrouverions bien entendu
devant un texte différent qui
empêcherait d'arriver à ce référendum
auquel nous
souhaitions donner suite donc ces
amendements ont pour principal objet de
défendre un certain nombre de points de
vue concernant cette ce projet de loi et
en particulier celui de l'amélioration
constante qui est un concept que
auxquels nous sommes attachés qui
consiste en fait à consacrer une
obligation positive pesant sur l'état
quant aux exigences de protection de
l'environnement qui s'est lui même fixé
l'objectif d'amélioration constante de
l'environnement n'a aujourd'hui qu'une
valeur législative inscrite à l'article
10 aux 110 points par du code de
l'environnement afin de renforcer sa
portée juridique et d'élargir son champ
d'application ce principe doit être
élevé au rang constitutionnel dans le
but de lui conférer une valeur égale à
celle des principes constitutionnels de
droit de propriété et de liberté des
entreprises généralement utilisé pour
autoriser la mise sur le marché par
exemple des néonicotinoïdes et de
certains produits phytosanitaires
expressivement nocifs pour la santé
l'environnement la france pourrait ainsi
être juridiquement mieux armé pour se
conformer aux objectifs instauré par
l'accord de paris qu'elle a elle même
signé et plus généralement ses
engagements internationaux en matière de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et de promotion de la
résilience
merci cher collègue monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement 9 sur le 5
secondes est identique couric numéro
trois sur le neuf c'est une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable d'abord
parce que il est contraire à la position
de la commission et la rédaction
proposée par la commission mais ce n'est
pas une raison suffisante
la deuxième raison c'est que la charte
de l'environnement prévoit déjà et
impose déjà à toute personne y compris
d'ailleurs aux pouvoirs publics de
prendre part à la préservation et à
l'amélioration de l'environnement
et je rappelle où je redis que la charte
de l'environnement fait partie également
du bloc constitutionnel avis défavorable
si monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président je suis défavorable à
l'ensemble de ces de ses amendements et
je veux redire tout de même que nous
avons fait un pas changer d'expression
d'ailleurs nous avons tendu la main au
sénat le gouvernement l'assemblée
nationale que vous vouliez ou non il y
avait deux mots qui était en discussion
il y en a un dont nous acceptions nous
acceptons pardon qu'ils soient changés
ça n'est pas notre initiative
le reste vous ne voulez pas bougé c'est
une réalité et chacun en tirera les
conclusions qui s'imposent et moi je
n'entends pas je n'entends plus vous
convaincre j'ai cru jusqu'à ce qu'il y à
quelques milles que vous pourriez
entendre raison tous les cas la raison
du gouvernement mais à l'évidence ça
n'est pas le cas je suis défavorable
bien sûr à six amendements n'entend pas
allonger artificiellement des débats je
n'ai sans doute comme vous pas le sens
de l'effort inutile j'ai bien compris
que vous n'en vouliez pas que vous ne
voudrez pas mais je persiste et je signe
si une petite modification est
intervenue ces de notre côté merci
monsieur le ministre c'est kerrouche oui
d'abord une petite précision aux propos
qui ont été tenus par monsieur le
questeur bas il a parlé du fait qu'il
n'y avait pas de distance entre le
groupe et l'air et la commission des
lois je pense qu'il voulait dire entre
le groupe et l'air et la majorité de la
commission des lois ça va sortir parce
que pour le reste on est plus que dans
le papier à cigarette
il ya beaucoup de tabac bien ça c'est le
premier ça c'est le premier ça c'est le
premier point le second sur cet
amendement
les deux identiques que nous ne voterons
pas le 3 et le 5 pour vous dire que le
jeu sémantique est certes intéressant
mais qu'il nous sommes que les
conséquences accordée au verbe garantir
par le groupe ait l'air nous semble
largement exagéré cela a été déjà dit
plusieurs fois je reparlerai de
l'indépendance des significations
endroit et le fait que le verbe garantir
n'a pas le même sens en droit
constitutionnel ou en droit pénal
notamment et que donc on est dans un
affrontement uniquement sémantique que
déjà la proposition du gouvernement
n'allait pas extrêmement loin mais que
la proposition qui nous est fait ne sert
à rien et qu'elle est extrêmement
tautologique dans sa formulation
notamment dans la référence qu'elle fait
à la charte de l'environnement de 2004
donc il nous apparaît évident qu'il est
nécessaire de voter contre ces deux
amendements
merci donc gelé mais on voit ces deux
amendements identiques le 3 et le 5
amendements donc je de la commission le
3 et le 5 1 il fera bien sûr un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ils sont
adoptés ils font tomber dans que
l'amendement 9 passoire amendement 12
mal à penser monge
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement est relatif au droit de vivre
dans un environnement sain et sur les
liens entre santé sécurité et
environnement ne sont plus à démontrer
aussi le groupe écologiste solidarité
territoire demande la consécration au
rang constitutionnel du droit des
générations actuelles et futures à vivre
dans un environnement sain les
nombreuses atteintes à la biodiversité
et à l'environnement pourrait à terme
générer la destruction de l'humanité
ainsi la france doit mettre en oeuvre
toutes les politiques environnementales
nécessaires afin de limiter l'impact des
activités humaines
un niveau permettant à l'humanité de
disposer des fonctions essentielles de
la biosphère
cette affirmation est surtout un
positionnement intergénérationnel nous
héritons nous n'héritons pas de la terre
de nos ancêtres nous l'empruntons à nos
enfants
cette formule est connue faut-il aussi
ne pas simplement la connaître mais
l'appliquer en appliquer les les
obligations le comité des droits de
l'homme des nations unies a le 30
octobre 2018 publier ses craintes quant
aux effets de la dégradation de
l'environnement
la dégradation de l'environnement le
changement climatique et le
développement non durable compte parmi
les menaces les plus imminente et les
plus graves qui pèsent sur le droit à la
vie des générations actuelles et futures
nous souhaitons ainsi rappelé l'impact
de nous
vision actuelle et leurs conséquences
sur les capacité des générations futures
à vivre dans de bonnes conditions
environnementales ce droit à un
environnement sain dans lequel on peut
inclure le droit à l'eau un air non
pollué au bénéfice de la biodiversité a
été reconnue en france est inscrit dans
la charte de l'environnement de 2005
il convient cependant d'en renforcer sa
portée juridique en érigeant ce droit en
principe constitutionnel inscrit à
l'article 1 de la constitution
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
j'ai l'impression que vous avez défendu
l'amendement 10 et donc on va peut-être
passer sur cet amendement on va on va
prendre cet amendement avant le 12 1
allez monsieur le rapporteur oui chers
collègues vous avez défendu
effectivement l'amendement numéro 10
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission mais comme vous l'avez
exprimez vous même la sarthe de
l'environnement participent déjà à
l'objet de votre amendement puisque je
donne notamment en faisant référence au
droit des générations futures et je
redis que la charte de l'environnement
et d'un bloc constitutionnel donc à bien
valeur constitutionnelle
donc c'est défavorable pour le dise
merci sur l'importance du ministre même
même avis mais ma vie donc je mets aux
veaux à cet amendement 10 avec deux avis
défavorables pied pour qui et contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée alors
cette fois-ci l'amendement 12 peut-être
madame pour se mange oui merci monsieur
le président une fille m excuser plus
qu'une notion générale de non régression
d'amélioration de l'environnement il est
nécessaire d'introduire un aspect
quantifiable des objectifs
environnementaux de notre pays ce
concept a été proposée par une équipe
internationale de 26 cherche chercheurs
dont les travaux ont été publiés dès
2009 est dores et déjà utilisée par des
grands groupes industriels privés qui
cherchent à confronter leur impact sur
l'environnement en regard de la capacité
de notre planète à l'absorber
l'objectif de l'inscription de ce
concept dans la constitution est très
claire
notre société ne doit pas évoluer au
détriment des capacités de notre planète
de ses ressources naturelles de sacs à
pain
cité éventuelle de renouveler de
renouvellement toute mesure quantifier
environnementale ne trouve son sens que
dans un cadre fini celui des limites
planétaires une limite d'émission ne
trouvera son sens et ne sera accepté par
la population que si elle est mise en
rapport avec le maximum qui serait
possible avant un déplacement des
ressources de la planète
ainsi cette inscription dans la
constitution solidifierait toute
démarche d'inscription dans le droit de
limites chiffrées d'émissions de co2 de
destruction forestière de limites de
pêche cola et monsieur rapporte un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
pour une raison simple c'est que c'est
ajout me paraît superflu d'une part et
d'autre part je vois mal comment on
pourrait préserver l'environnement sans
respecter par définition des limites
planétaires demandé par les auteurs de
l'amendement donc défavorable
merci même avis monsieur le ministre
madame pour ce mensonge oui merci
monsieur le rapporteur mais c'est
pourtant ce que nous faisons vous savez
très bien que chaque année le jour du
dépassement et est de plus en plus tôt
donc nous le faisons vous dites vous on
ne voit pas comment on pourrait ne pas
le faire et bien si depuis plus depuis
toujours nous le faisons et donc il
s'agit effectivement que jours de
déplacement de dépassement ne soit plus
au mois d'août 1,1 au mois de juillet et
au mois de juin mais retourne où il doit
être c'est à dire en décembre merci cher
collègue monsieur va pour explication de
vote
je ne voterai pas cet amendement mais je
me demande s'il n'est pas inutilement
restrictif
parce que nous sommes tous conscients
des difficultés croissantes situer dans
l'espace avec une pollution de l'espace
par des particules métalliques qui
résulte des objets satellisé que nous
avons envoyé bien au delà de
l'atmosphère et qui justifierait je
crois mais peut-être la réflexion
pourrait-elle s'engager avec votre
groupe chers collègues qu'on prenne en
compte non seulement les limites
planétaires mais aussi
les limites interstellaire c'est un
sous-amendement non bon alors je mets au
voile amendement 12 avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée
damman dangereux de penser monge
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement est relatif au principe de
non régression la gestion d'un futur
durable doit permettre de garantir que
les acquis environnementaux ne soit pas
remis en question le principe de non
régression protège les droits des
générations futures en renforçant les
exigences écologiques dans la prise de
décision l'effectivité d'un droit humain
l'environnement ne devient réalité qu'à
la condition d'une garantie juridique
que chaque avancée pour la préservation
de l'environnement ne puisse être
ultérieurement remise en cause ce
principe n'implique pas une
impossibilité d'action de la part des
autorités mais crée une obligation
positive notamment pour le législateur
de ne pas dégrader les avancées
écologiques
toutefois en dépit de l'urgence
climatique certaines des décisions
législatives ou réglementaires sont
moins disantes au niveau environnemental
et son retour sur la protection de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
est insupportable au vu des dernières
décisions qui ont permis aux juges de
valider ce retour en arrière sur la lime
limitation des néonicotinoïdes il est
essentiel de marquer qu'à défaut de
faire plus on ne peut plus se permettre
de faire loin merci cher collègue
monsieur rapporteur un avis défavorable
à cet amendement
je voudrais rappeler d'abord que il
partiellement satisfaite puisque nos
espérances du conseil constitutionnel
actuel a bien consacrer le principe de
non régression dans une décision de
vider du 10 décembre pardon dernier le
conseil a dégagé de la charte de
l'environnement un principe de non
régression tempéré en matière
d'environnement
il a considéré je veux le dire d'abord
que les sept heures ne seraient privés
de garanties légales le droit de vivre
dans un environnement équilibré et
respectueux de la santé consacrée par
l'article premier de la charte de
l'environnement
il a par ailleurs considéré que la
limitation les limitations porté par
l'initiateur à l'exercice de ce droit ne
saurait être que lier des exigences
constitutionnelles ou justifiée par un
motif d'intérêt général et
proportionnées à l'objectif poursuivi
est enfin que le législateur doit
prendre en compte le devoir de prendre
part à la préservation et à
l'amélioration de l'environnement
mentionné aux dispositions de l'article
2 de la charte de 2004 la raison pour
laquelle c'est un avis défavorable
il paraît déraisonnable en l'état
d'aller plus loin les pouvoirs publics
doivent être en mesure de prendre les
dispositions rendue nécessaire par
l'intérêt général et ou par tout autre
exigence constitutionnelle à vis des
favoris merci monsieur ministre même
avis défavorable dont je me sauve voix
l'amendement 11 avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour qui comptent
qui s'abstient il est n'est pas adopté
je mets au voile article unique m
qui est pour l'article unique qui est
contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté après cet article de
l'amendement 2 monsieur hainaut merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
cet amendement est plus d'inspiration
bretonne que je dis ou picarde
il est l'auteur de cette can get et vise
l'apprentissage des langues régionales
et notamment son inscription dans notre
constitution
pour ce qui concerne l'apprentissage
intensif de ces langues régionales qui
sont une richesse un patrimoine commun
et qui participe à la diversité de nos
territoires jour merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur
c'est une demande de retrait en réalité
messi n'est pas retirée ce sera un avis
défavorable il n'est plus l'objet de cet
amendement n'est pas dans l'objet du
texte lui même qui se concentre sur la
notion environnementale au sein de la
constitution merci monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie
la vie mais chez nous il est maintenu il
est mature donc je le mets aux voix avec
deux avis défavorables
l'amendement de qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'amendement à monsieur nô alors
c'est la même inspiration il consiste à
donner plus de liberté aux exécutifs
locaux pour la représentation des epc
c'est au nom de la liberté fondamentale
reconnue par le conseil d'état des
collectivités territoriales je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues et monsieur
rapporteur c'est un avis défavorable
pour une raison assez clair c'est qu'on
ne comprend pas bien en tous les cas
l'objet de l'amendement qui vise à
inscrire dans les dispositions de
l'article 72 de la constitution que les
collectivités territoriales
s'administrent librement par des
conseils élus et ils et rajoutez y
compris pour la représentation dans les
établissements publics de coopération
c'est peut-être cause sur le fond il ya
un sujet et une discussion est également
une discussion sur le fait que ce n'est
pas dans l'objet de la faune
constitutionnelle que nous avons à
étudier merci monsieur le ministre même
avis défavorable donc je mets ce voile
amendement a avec deux avis défavorables
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il n'est pas adopté mes chers collègues
je mettre aux voix l'ensemble du projet
de loi constitutionnelle
y at il des demandes d'explications de
vote oui même jour là merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
quelques mots pour expliquer la position
du groupe l'est républicain mais je
pense que vous aurez aisément saisi
quelle est cette position je voudrais
tout de même dire à monsieur le garde
des sceaux que nous ne croyons garni ni
à la main tendue ni opa qui aurait été
fait par l'assemblée nationale vers le
sénat par l'utilisation de
ces termes aj poudre car en réalité ce
n'est jamais que l'adoption des
recommandations qui avait été faite par
le conseil d'état et non pas une
manifestation de bienveillance à notre
égard de l'assemblée nationale nous
sommes bien sûr aussi inquiets de
l'utilisation du terme garantie qui est
décrit tantôt comme une une quasi
obligation de résultat ou comme une
obligation de moyens renforcés et dont
en réalité personne n'est capable de
dire quelle est la portée juridique
la réalité est que ce que nous
souhaitons et vous l'aurez compris et
que la préservation de l'environnement
ne se fasse pas au détriment du progrès
social ni au détriment du développement
économique
c'est à dire qu'elle se fasse dans le
cadre des principes du développement
durable qui sont prévues par l'article 6
de la charte de l'environnement
c'est pourquoi le groupe l'est
républicain suivra dans son immense
majorité
la position qui a été celle du
rapporteur françois noël buffet que nous
remercions de cette position merci chers
collègues je ne vois pas d'autres
explications de vote jeu mais l'ensemble
du projet de loi constitutionnelle en
application de l'article 59 du règlement
le scrutin public ordinaire et de droit
il va être procédé dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 156 du règlement de
scrutin est ouvert
c
un nom à voter le scrutin est clos
l'état du scrutin 156 sur l'ensemble du
texte compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs au groupe politique est
notifié la présidence nombre de votants
342 nombre de suffrages exprimés 337
pour l'adoption 210 contre 127
le sénat a adopté
[Musique]